all right another day another dollar and
uh today we'll be talking about raft um
so if you don't know raft is it's a
consensus algorithm that came out in
2014 more or less and it's been really
popular actually getting a ton of usage
even compared to uh you know like older
ones like paxos and the reason for that
is that it is pretty easy to understand
and it was made so that it was easy to
understand and so i guess if my dumb ass
at 21 can understand it then i will be
proving to the writers of the paper that
they're doing a good job so let's get
into it and see if your dumb asses can
also understand it
okay raft what is it well raft is really
just a consensus algorithm that has some
level of fault tolerance what this means
is that we can use it to build a
replicated log so basically every single
position in the log is a decision that
is made by the raft algorithm and as
such we can use this to create total
order broadcast eventually every single
node will have the same exact log which
means that we have this idea of eventual
consistency and um you know if you're if
you've ever heard of something like
paxos or actually multipaxos to create a
fully replicated log which is kind of
just meaning that you're doing paxos but
for multiple stages so every single
entry of the log
there are a lot of similarities there
but they're not identical so in terms of
how it's actually used as you can see
imagine we have these three database
replicas at the bottom of the screen
here
and every single replica has a log
associated with it imagine that's like
the right ahead log and this log is
going to be running in a raft instance
on the database
and all it's going to have is the
operation on the log and then something
called a term number which i'll explain
later as you can see they're not all
completely identical but eventually they
will be
okay so before we get into this i'm just
going to do a quick review term because
you know if you haven't watched all of
these videos then some of these might
not make sense to you and i'll be using
them throughout so first of all what's a
quorum a quorum is a majority of nodes
in any cluster of nodes in this case
it's a majority of nodes in a database
cluster of replicas and so basically the
point of using a quorum is that if two
different quorums of nodes have made
some decision as in all of the nodes in
that quorum agree on something they
cannot make conflicting decisions
because that means that one of those
nodes must overlap within the two
quorums and so it's impossible to have a
conflicting decision because one node
can't decide two different things about
say the same entry of a log
additionally we discussed something
called a fencing token in a previous
video which is basically just what the
term number is in raft it's an
increasing number used in situations
like split brain where there might be
multiple leaders or even with a locking
system to basically go ahead and say you
know take the higher number that one
wins and so if there's ever a conflict
about you know two nodes believing that
they have this one resource whether
that's being the leader holding a lock
the higher fencing number wins
and then finally we have this concept of
a leader in raft the leader takes all of
the rights and even some of the reads if
you want strong consistency but there
are other ways to get strong consistency
on reads by doing things like quorum
reads and a leader is going to go ahead
and take in all the writes and propagate
those to the other nodes which are known
as followers
so let's quickly go over the way that
raft works on like a very high level and
then i'll dive into how each of these
pieces actually works so basically like
i mentioned there's one leader at at
least at a time there's one leader per
term where each term is identified by a
number and the leader is going to send
all of the writes for that term to the
follower nodes once a leader receives
responses from a quorum of the nodes so
that would be a majority it can go ahead
and tell them to commit those rights to
the above database layer once they're
committed the above database layer is
going to put them in their key value
store and then finally reads can
actually go ahead and read that key in
value
and then finally the biggest thing here
is that one of the things i've mentioned
in my past videos for mainly single read
single leader replication is that if a
leader leader's presumed dead
you kind of just have to do a failover
but that's not always an easy process to
do and it's not always automatic but in
this case if a leader is presumed dead
a follower node is actually going to
potentially go ahead and try and become
the new leader and once that happens
there is consensus reached amongst the
following nodes about who the new leader
is and we don't have to worry about
split brand raft actually goes ahead and
solves that for us
okay
so let's talk about leader election
first because this is kind of the big
reason why raft works which is that
there is only one leader and there can
only be one leader at a time per term
okay so basically
in raft every node is either a leader a
candidate or a follower so let's start
by talking about the followers each
follower node these are nodes that are
going to be accepting rights
periodically receives heartbeats from
the leader to basically say hi i'm still
up and running don't try and replace me
however if a follower node doesn't
receive a heartbeat within within some
amount of time out where um this timeout
is typically the length of a few
heartbeats um up to you know the amount
of time that it might take for a new
election process to ensue it will assume
the leader to be dead and declare itself
to be the state of candidate
once a node calls itself a candidate
it's going to start a new election
process vote for itself and tell all the
other nodes that it's starting set
election process it's also going to
increase its internal turn number which
i'll maybe call a local term number
later by one so it's saying this is a
new term we're going to have a new
leader or maybe the same leader as
before but it's going to be under a new
term number
next in addition
because this follower node who's now a
candidate node is going to have to have
a majority of votes to become a leader
we don't want every single follower
starting new elections at the same time
because if they do they're all going to
vote for themselves and then no node is
actually going to be elected a leader so
we do we randomize the timeouts that
each follower node has on it locally to
determine when a leader is dead and what
this does is it means that a follower
node will typically you know one might
go off and say oh i think the leader is
dead and the others will still think the
leader is alive but know that a vote is
going on so that heartbeat timer is
going to be randomized uniformly over
some distribution where the distribution
is the length probably at minimum of a
few heartbeats but also still enough to
make sure that an entire election
process can ensue without some other
node saying wait i think i'm the
candidate and now i want to try myself
okay
so let's keep talking about leader
election because now we have to talk
about what happens when a follower node
receives word that a new node is the
candidate
well there are a few things that we have
to check firstly if the candidate term
number is higher than the local term
number
the local basically the the follower
node that is going to receive the fact
that there's an election needs to become
a follower and that's the case even if
that node was a leader and then
additionally change their local term
number to the candidate term number now
we're saying okay we're moving on to a
new term everyone has to update this
fact
additionally we're going to go ahead and
say if the candidate log is more up to
date than the local log and you know
i'll talk about how you can kind of
determine if a log is more up to date
than another because there might even be
conflicts there but if the candidate log
is more up to date than the local log
and the node aka the the local node
hasn't voted for any other candidate
this term and it knows if it has because
it's kind of keeping track of what term
it is and what nodes it's voted for in a
given term the node will reply saying
that okay you have my vote
if those conditions aren't met so either
the candidate log is not enough up to
date or
the node's already voted for someone
else this term
it does not vote for the candidate and
it responds to the candidate saying i'm
not voting for you
so once the candidate receives all these
responses it tallies them up and
basically it says okay if i reach
two-thirds or not two-thirds but rather
a majority of nodes in the cluster if i
get a response saying that they voted
for me i'll declare myself the leader
otherwise we have this concept of an
election timeout and if it doesn't hear
back from all the other nodes eventually
it's going to say okay i give up on this
election
okay broadcasting messages so
we now discussed how we have our leader
how's the leader actually going to pass
these rights to the follower nodes well
the leader is going to receive a message
to broadcast so it might either receive
that from the client itself or the
client gives it to one of the other
nodes and the other nodes passes it to
the leader via a fifo channel so we make
sure all those messages are coming in
the same order
and then it's going to go ahead and add
it to its local log but also make sure
not to commit it what that means is that
even though the message is in the log
the database part can't actually see the
message and won't make the change and
it's going to go ahead and send it to
all the other nodes
via a function which for now i'm just
going to call replicate log
and then additionally replicate log is
going to be called periodically so that
kind of acts as the heartbeat that a
leader sends to follower nodes in the
event that another election needs to
happen and then finally it also helps
that replicate log is periodically
called so the leader can alert the other
nodes if there are any new messages to
actually commit which means you know
tell the database hey this is a valid
write okay
so let's talk about this replicate log
function because this is pretty
important
because this is kind of like why raft
works so for each node what's going to
happen is this the leader has its local
copy of the log and for that local copy
the leader is now keeping track of every
single follower and how many messages
that it's sent to the follower and how
many messages that the follower has
acknowledged that they've received from
the leader and using this it can try and
determine which messages the follower
has on hand which it'll call a prefix
and then all of the new messages that
the leader contains but they assume the
follower doesn't contain is called the
suffix so what it's going to do is send
all of the messages
from the suffix so new messages that
they assume the follower doesn't yet
have
to that follower and in addition it's
going to send the term number
of the last entry of the prefix so i'm
going to explain why it does that in a
second
another thing to note is that the leader
is not always right about what the
prefix and the suffix are for each note
it might be the case that a certain
follower node has less of the correct
messages in its log than the leader
originally thought and if that's the
case it's going to have to go back and
make further changes so i'll explain
that in a bit but right now all that's
important is we're going ahead and
sending those suffix messages to be
appended on the follower and we're also
sending the term number of the last
entry of the prefix why are we sending
that term number of the last entry of
the prefix well because there is an
invariant about every single replicated
log in raft which basically says this if
the logs on two replicas have the same
term number at the same index in the log
they must be the same up to and
including that index so looking here at
these two database replicas as you can
see in index two assuming this is a zero
index log we have the entry c for the
operation so like write c
and then the term number is four
we know that if these guys have the same
term number it means that the leader has
written to both of them and as a result
of that anything beforehand must have
been correct so that the leader could
have written to them in the first place
something like this situation is not
possible right here where you know they
both have c4 and that two entry but then
you know they differ in the zero with
entry with a3 and d2
um if you think about this in variant a
little bit more it's you know kind of a
lot to think about but it eventually
becomes clear why it works um you know
if you want to pause this video and
reason read my note here you definitely
can
but the general point is we know that um
the leader is right and that's the
reason it was elected in the first place
so if the follower has a different
prefix at a point the leader needs to go
ahead and overwrite that prefix and
not just make new appends the log it's
got to go ahead and change its logic
okay sorry my roommate came in
mid-recording so basically continuing to
talk about the replicate log function
because the invariant just previously
mentioned we basically know that if the
term number at the end of the prefixes
are the same we can just go ahead and
copy over that suffix and put in those
correct messages and then the the log of
the follower will be the same as the log
of the leader um if the prefixes aren't
not the same then we know that the
assumption that the leader made about
what the follower already has in its log
is bad and we're going to have to go
ahead and report that back to the leader
additionally
when the leader commits the suffixes to
the followers which it only does if the
prefixes are correct then we'll go ahead
and have the follower check for newly
committed messages so that i can commit
those to the database layer
okay in terms of receiving right
acknowledgements on the leader
as we just mentioned the reader wants a
quorum of right acknowledgements so if
it receives a majority of
you know acknowledgments for a
successful write for a given log entry
it's going to go ahead and keep track of
these and once it reaches that quorum it
goes ahead commits it locally and then
sends that commit out to all of the
followers
additionally if it hears the write
wasn't successful it must be because the
prefix of the leader and the follower
node were not the same
or because of the fact that they had a
different term number between them and
if the term number of the follower is
higher than the leader
the leader now knows that
it's no longer the leader and has to
give up its leader status and transition
to follower if it's because the prefix
of the follower was not up to date
enough then what the leader is going to
try and do is try to replicate the log
again but with a smaller prefix and see
if it works this time and that might
potentially be a loop that spans very
far where you just keep adjusting the
prefix to be smaller and smaller
assuming that the follower knows less
and less until you finally reach the
amount of the log that they have in
common and then you can go ahead and
replicate what you have
okay so in conclusion
even though the raft paper is from 2014
like i mentioned it's gained a ton of
popularity because it's ease of
understandability and i just explained
it to you guys in basically 15 minutes
so clearly it's not that bad
and it's hugely popular it still takes a
ton of network coordination in order to
do all this stuff you basically have to
reach out to every node or at least
attempt to do so and get
acknowledgements from a majority of them
compared to two-phase commit though the
fact that it's so tolerant is really
great that being said there are still
times where two-phase commit is more
useful than raft and the main example of
that are things like atomic commit
across partitions obviously in raft if
we want to make rights to multiple
partitions it's not enough for only a
majority of them to say okay yeah i got
this all of them have to acknowledge it
and then maybe within the partitions um
you know obviously we replicate each
partition you can use something like
raft
nonetheless it's really important to
understand this algorithm as it gives a
great idea of
kind of a lot of the concepts that we've
talked about such as quorums fencing
tokens and even just like two-phase
commit in general how there's kind of
this idea of a prepare phase and then
eventually committing that right to the
database layer
ultimately it's really important to know
about raft and not necessarily every
step of it but generally what you might
use it for and additionally in
subsequent videos how it differs from
other consensus algorithms like paxos or
zap and i'll get to those eventually too
well either way guys this is probably
the most theoretical video i've had so
far but i hope it was easy enough to
understand and have a great day